let's jump into the store we got this
from the post millennial police on high
alert following death threats from
Atlanta Forest Defenders I just wanna I
just want to pause right there and say
um I'm gonna text Libby can I text Libby
she's entering Chief um what's with this
headline I was gonna say that's my mom's
name texted my mom dude Forest Defenders
what do you mean you mean domestic
terrorists you mean the city of Atlanta
is on high alert after antifa domestic
terrorists opened fire on police and
then called for assassinations come on
post-millennial you guys can do better
than this here's the story
seven it's from Andy no post millennial
seven charged with domestic terrorism
following deadly shooting at Atlanta
autonomous Zone
these people firebombed buildings
people are not from the Atlanta area
they were arrested and turns out they're
from all over the place so these random
psychopaths are coming down to Atlanta
feigning some kind of outrage over a
police training center
fire bombing people's firebombing houses
under construction not people living
there
a dude in a truck is driving up they
fire bomb his truck random innocent guy
he gets out and flees they destroyed his
truck flip it over
police job to stop him the guy shoots a
cop severely injuring him
the police returned fire and
self-defense antifa responds by issuing
a direct call for the assassination of
police in the area putting the city on
high alert hey I didn't I didn't have
that one on my 2023 bingo card but it
probably should have been right
um yeah who I'm not even hearing about
this in the news I mean I didn't know
that there was another autonomous it's
been there for like a year and a half
yeah which which is absolutely crazy
because the last time we kind of saw
this it was in Portland and it was
widely talked about and people were
trying to film in there but there's
there's nothing about any of this that
I've been actually hearing about myself
but to be fair I mean we were really
wrapped up talking about Stephen Crowder
yesterday I mean we couldn't we couldn't
spare any time I talk about antifa
terrorists getting arrested and trying
to kill police so is this a situation
where they're like this is our land and
then the cop stepped on their land and
they're like don't you're invading our
territory Bang Bang the cops were going
to use the facility as a training
facility right they want to build a
training center exactly and so a bunch
of
Psychopaths from all over the country
show up pretending they're angry that
Atlanta's doing this and then living in
trees and trying to kill people yeah
underground repeat stuff you remember
the story yeah but I don't think the
Weather Underground ever like almost
killed a cop didn't they bombed yeah
they did yeah but but my understanding
is that they were doing shock and awe
that they were intentionally trying to
avoid killing people but they were
trying to destroy stuff yeah so I could
be wrong I don't know I'm not an expert
on that so one when I'm so from what I'm
seeing online it looks like there was a
multi-agency operation that got rid of
25 campsites that were on this
autonomous Zone and they were able to
find a lot of weapons a lot of different
fireworks uh pellet rifles gas masks
boat uh boat torches uh but uh it looks
like there was a scuffle when of course
they were being kicked out of this
location I'm I'm I thought I heard a
story about The Weather Underground
having killed the cop or something but I
think when I do a Google search like I
think the only thing I find is they kill
themselves they were working on a bomb
in a basement it blew up and killed them
because my understanding is that a lot
of people talk about the weather
underground and you know compare it to
what's going on today with antifa and
then I often hear from you know people
who are more experts than I that yeah
but they were doing shock and awe
campaigns they would go two in the
morning when no one was around and blow
something up to be like aha look at us
whereas antifa literally just kills
people like the dude in Portland they
walked up and just shot him in the chest
that BLM guy and then you have all the
people who died I'll call this one
indirect far left you know death the
riots the summer of love but this is
like an escalation this is they shot a
cop put them in the hospital yeah we're
in an age now where you can radical well
you can rally much quicker with like
social media groups like Facebook groups
so there's a lot more
um instances of people identifying with
group names now like there's a lot of
different types of antifa groups that
are they probably don't even know each
other they're just saying yeah I'll do
that too I'll put a label on my shirt
and so there's going to be more likely
you're going to see like random acts of
violence and things I think the Weather
Underground is a much more focused group
that started apparent only in the campus
of the University of Michigan 1969 and
they probably knew each other pretty
well I don't know how it was Bill Ayers
who was a high level Foundation guy who
was basically funding and promoting all
that so that was actually an
establishment created thing which I
think antifa is as well so that's why I
was making the Weather Underground
connection and
um I think it's the same thing with uh
they gave a six minute warning before
bombing the New York Police Headquarters
The Weather Underground yeah
okay have you seen that interview where
they say though the they're interviewing
the weather on around people they're
like well we want to put half of America
into camps
what yeah Alex plays that clip all the
time it's just it's that they had the
attitude that half of America would have
to be re-educated so they were the first
to call for re-education camps yeah
Andrew Cuomo a very popular uh Governor
from uh New York former Governor
actually commuted a sentence for an ex
whether Underground member recently as
well which he was personally um you know
intervened and defended his decision in
doing so there's a vintage debate
between Lord Voldemort and Bill Ayers
it's pretty interesting I don't know if
anybody could ever dig that up but they
go into that and Alex actually brings
all that up
what was the topic of the debate what
were they discussing well Ayers was
trying to argue that he was actually
working for real liberalism and real
liberal causes and I think he was making
points that Tim was trying to make that
that they weren't really wanting to
supposedly hurt people but that it was a
real liberal movement knox's argument
that it wasn't so that it was Foundation
funded like a push oh interesting yeah
so Ayers was like working at high level
foundation so what as a liberal you know
what the fact I don't remember if it was
a Ford Foundation something like that he
had some connection to a high level I
don't remember which one it was and then
so they played it off as if they were
anti-vietnam or something anti-war
anti-establishment what was the real
goal empowering the state
uh that depends on how legitimate I
guess the Weather Underground themselves
were I mean if whether they were
completely fed created thing or whether
it was
um a kind of a steered into radicalism
uh you know a lot of the cointelpro was
designed to do that steer people into
appearing radical it was a Richard Aoki
was the guy who steered the Panthers
into being radical and that basically
defused all of their PR right because
they were they were seen walking around
carrying guns and America thought oh the
Black Panthers are going to take over
America so it was nest psyop and that's
exactly why I tell people the violence
doesn't work it's what the government
wants exactly when you get when you get
violent or scary the government can then
take that use it against you and justify
expansion because regular people say yes
please government don't do this when
antifa goes out and do it the media
covers it up never talks about it so no
one knows it's happening but you would
think if the media did talk about it
that would be a reason to fund the FBI
to investigate with us so what the heck
is going on because antifa is doing
things that they want I suppose I don't
know I mean look look at the Gretchen
Whitmer thing it's like 14 FBI agents
and like two dudes and they try and lock
them up they want the narrative to be
the far rights dangerous they don't want
the narrator to be the far left as
dangerous because they want to stop
Trump things like that
presumably my guess
so the keeping antifa in their back
pocket as a militant arm of of the
liberal and economic order in case I
don't know things don't go the way that
the business is moving it I think
there's far right and far left that are
kind of managed like they serve a
purpose both of these groups and you'll
notice the history of you know
cointelpro there's usually Federal
informants in all of these whether it's
radical Islam groups look up the Newberg
sting documentary it's a classic because
people like Ray Epps we still haven't
gotten answers about there you go what's
he on about you know what's the name my
favorite news story was a couple years
ago of uh the ATF busting down an FBI
ring because they were both undercover
and hearing stories like that uh you
know it just just gives me a little bit
of hope you ever hear that story of the
dude who set he created a fake grow
house he rented a house and then he put
grow lights in it Barry Cooper is that
is that I believe so and then so what
happened was
he knew that the DEA and the police were
doing illegal raids without warrants on
grow houses so he rents a house and he
puts very powerful grow lights in it and
nothing else but live streaming cameras
then of course one day they storm into
the house they break in without a
warrant and there's live streaming
cameras everywhere and there's like a
sign saying you're on camera or
something like that yeah I believe this
was Barry Cooper he was previously one
of the top best narcotics officers in
this entire country he got multiple
prestigious Awards by many federal
agencies and then he just realized that
the War on Drugs was absolutely stupid
and he dedicated his life towards
exposing how much of of of of a con this
was and then started to do tutorial
videos about how to get away with drug
dealing and and literally made tutorial
videos saying okay drug sniffing dogs do
this make sure you do this to not get
caught so uh that's another uh we uh
interesting individual that I met
previously before we put up a poll in
the chat right now who is Right Crowder
daily wire just to get your guys's
thoughts on the whole thing happened
this week Luke put up a poll I like my
poll what does your poll say well my
poll says uh let me just pull it up here
to see who's actually the winner here
but we need a third option here you
always need a third option I think your
option is like Democrat or Republicans
but
um surprisingly it's tied my poll is who
is in the right I have Crowder option
one daily wire option two and both are
status and both are wrong option three
uh is tied with daily wire oh at 36
right now it's tied oh yeah so votes
happening on my Twitter look we are
changing if you want to get involved in
that I personally voted for the third
option but that's just me uh but you
know let let the people speak let the
let the people vote both our statists
and wrong how's it going I couldn't vote
because I I just didn't I don't believe
any of them are wrong I usually don't
believe in voting but yeah I shouldn't I
should have on Twitter I put abstain and
most people said Epstein like I don't
want to be involved Jeffrey Epstein
[Laughter]
yeah so I don't know man what do you
guys think huh is 2023 going to be the
year where it kicks off and gets you
know hot conflict are we going to see
the Resurgence of the crazy antifa stuff
we saw a couple years ago or is this
anomalous there's also another crazy
story just a couple days ago of of of a
guy who lost a local election and then
went up and shot up and shot up the home
offices of uh the the Democrats the
Democrats so you know that's another you
know story that I I think uh can you
believe should be talked about our first
swatting was one year ago this month oh
happy anniversary yeah it was the sixth
it was January 6th our first one
congrats yeah 15 15 times since then if
we sit by and just complain it will
we'll see more violence and probably the
the dissolution of the United States but
if we actively create technology and
structures and communities that are
resilient to this kind of thing I think
we'll easily be able to bypass this and
remain a global leader so so I think
personally that there is a larger divide
and conquer agenda meant for for the
American people to tear each other up
beat each other up and find each other
as each other's enemies meanwhile the
real kind of culprits the real kind of
people behind the scenes that are
hurting both people are getting away
with a lot of their crimes against
humanity and seeing the the point that
we are at right now where a lot of
people are even afraid to have civil
conversations at the dinner table with
each other's family members seeing at
the situation where we are so polarized
we are so divided the ingredients that
created to that situation the social
media algorithms the divisive emotional
hyperbolic psyops the the news coverage
that that again is used to manipulate
people all those ingredients haven't
gone away you add that to the larger
ingredients of of people getting sicker
getting more unhealthier not just
physically but also mentally you add
that to Poverty increasing uh we're
we're we have a recipe for disaster with
all these ingredients kind of coming
here together and I think it's it's only
going to get way worse from here which
is absolutely horrible and something
that should be prevented and we should
have a real conversation about but sadly
we don't have that conversation and
sadly these ingredients are just being
being added to this larger mess of a
situation that we're all in when you say
only getting worse like what do you mean
exactly because I know things will get
better as well but what do you mean so
as far as like mental health right
mental health has been declining
dramatically in this country that's
going to have a severe effect on whether
people act violently you look at the
destruction of the family unit when you
look at the radicalization that happens
uh not just in the Middle East but but
with any kind of form of radicalism one
of the key components is not only low
intelligence but it's also low income
not a lot of abilities and not banging
at all not having the opportunity to
find a a female or male spouse they
attribute to this specifically in the
Middle East because there's a lot of men
that have multiple lives meaning that
there's a lot of guys who can't have a
wife meaning that they're more likely to
be radicalized now with the destruction
of the family unit people becoming
poorer people becoming more crazier
there's going to be more violence in the
United States whether we like it or not
because they they promise them 72
virgins in heaven
this is a story uh it's a crazy story I
was reading about uh hashash the
hashashin I think it was called it's
like the origination of the Assassins
yeah basically this dude would drug
young men and then drag their bodies to
a like a poppy field with a bunch of
like beautiful women dancing around and
then they'd wake up and he'd be like
this is Paradise look at all these women
they're all yours and they'd be like oh
how do I what is this like oh but you
can only get it if you serve and do what
you're told and he's like oh and then
they drug him again drag them back to
where they were before and then they
wake up and like what was that vision
and he's like if you do everything I say
you will go back there and so the
Assassins people don't understand
they they it's like we have this vision
of Assassins as you know ninjas wearing
all black crawling in through the
ceiling taking out the emperor and then
like throwing a rope and scurrying away
and that's not at all the assassins the
true assassins would dress like a
pre-store farmer walk in stab the crap
out of the leader and then be killed on
the spot by the leader supporters they
were they were like ah now I can go to
paradise or whatever so suicide bombers
of the day exactly yep yeah there were
people being poor not getting laid and
then having more mental health problems
and a lot of sand that is yeah yeah no
jokes and in places where you know yeah
that's why the fasting I think from
Ramadan is so important because it would
keep this super the hot heat you can't
you can't discount the hot heat of the
Middle East the hottest part yeah hot
heat
um it's not bad by the way great band
yeah
basically what led to Nazi Germany it
was the was the extreme degradation
poverty it wasn't the same surprising it
wasn't the heat um but it was like
environments where people didn't have no
money there yeah World War One created
that situation where of course they were
made to sign a treaty that essentially
robbed them of a lot of their wealth and
no you make you make a great Point
there's a there's a a some study or
something I remember hearing about this
during the Arab Spring three components
that led to the revolutions and it was
like the high cost of food the uh
inability to work and like a lack of
shelter or something like this like I
can't remember what the exact components
were but when when you have high levels
of homelessness unemployment and
inflation
for obvious reasons everything falls
apart I mean yeah or people become like
vulnerable to a strong personality
coming along and saying I can help you
that's the problem whether it's a person
or thing we will destroy that thing and
then you'll be okay and people are like
I'm so desperate
anything is better than starvation my
question for Jay is everything we're
seeing manufactured
uh not in US I mean in a in a sense uh I
think you have all these books in front
of you talking about the global Elites
and all that you hear from them all the
time about how they want less people uh
that lower population growth they want
more control and then I look at all the
stuff like why doesn't the media cover
antifa why do they run cover for antifa
and it's almost like they're serving
some kind of purpose yeah well I mean
the mass media is a creation of the same
people that set up the Davos the setup
Bilderberg to set up all the things that
we know of as the control structure
right now so the United Nations is a
creation of this same group and so if
you look at the history of the the
networks CBS NBC those were all run by
people who came out of wartime OSS
intelligence and they just took all of
that information that they learned from
wartime and applied it to mass media so
mass media has basically been that for
this entire time I was just watching
some old Walter Cronkite award reception
ceremonies and he was getting awards for
Global governance back in the 80s and he
was like a you know hardcore Global uh
promoter
um and he was a big promoter of
depopulation as well and so that's
definitely one of the themes other to
talk the Ten Commandments of the global
Elite and that's one of those key key
Commandments is you have to maintain you
know population down at least under a
billion that's the near-term goal so and
the OSS was a predator accessor to the
CIA a lot of people need to realize that
as well what are the other tenants you
said there are 10 tenets of globalism
yeah I just basically went through a lot
of these texts and just kind of figured
it out what were the commonalities and
just kind of came up with my own 10 but
I mean it's you know it's a world
economic system based around you know
some form of universal basic income it's
a world religion uh I mean they all
write about that but focus them the
first thing the first thing you
mentioned uh the Central Bank digital
currency than the local religion and
also the the Turning of the actual
existing establishment religions into
something that is a form of wokism yeah
like the Vatican this kind of stuff in
my view
um you know they push it the vatican's
pushing World economic foreign
principles and inclusive capitalism
which is you know to Klaus has another
book inclusive capitalism so
um it's about attending as a cabinets
um that's not one of the Ten
Commandments penetration that's a key
component
um you know the the the creation of a
single government the creation of a
technocratic central order I mean the
Kissinger of France Jakarta Lee I
brought his book I mean his whole book
is about transhumanism basically being
the spirit the tip of the spear for uh
the New World Order he calls it that
like he says the whole chapter on this
is like the tip of the sphere is
transhumanism so that's another one of
these tenets how would transhumanism
function as a tip of the spear I mean
the first way I think of it is that they
can read your thoughts with a neural net
and then they can control your behavior
through that the other idea would be
that they make people so depressed that
they are become vulnerable to
manipulation let me give a quick shout
out to Stargate sg1
on an episode that I've talked about
before
those unfamiliar the show's Amazing by
the way it's a a team travels through a
Stargate portal to various coordinates
to explore other colonies essentially
like other planets and you know it's
it's complicated but uh basically they
go to one place where they they send out
a drone little robot and everything's
destroyed but then all of a sudden it
flashes and everything's fine there's a
barrier over this small town where
everything outside of it is polluted and
this force field is keeping everybody
safe
they go inside they meet people
eventually they're like Hey where's that
guy we met and they go what guy and
they're like the guy John we met John
and they were like there's no one here
by that name and they're like what
randomly one person just leaves the city
and walks out to their death
what was happening was everyone had a
neural implant the Central Computer was
controlling their memories and when the
force field was shrinking as it ran out
of power it would excise people by
altering their brains to make them walk
to their death and then make everyone
forget they existed
that could be happening right now and
you wouldn't know it memory holding yeah
we could like fro there's another seat
right here guys look at this there's a
chair it's got it's empty
uh for all we know
there was a lost fifth
person
erased is that really is that part of
the plan uh how deep have you have you
peered pretty pretty is what part of
like having like memory yeah
they're really skinny dude controlling
people's minds I mean uh interesting
that's totally real I mean you know
there's a history of DARPA text that
Annie Jacobson wrote uh it's a really
good book um and she well I think she
got nominated from Pulitzer she didn't
win it but she did that other famous
book on Area 51 but in her history of
DARPA she talks about how the there's
actually collusion between Hollywood and
DARPA to have symbiotic relationship
between
the creators of TV shows taking ideas
like you're talking about Stargate and
then they have a reciprocal relationship
with DARPA where they get fed ideas and
they feed ideas to people at DARPA so
there's a whole chapter in that too
about MK Ultra I don't know if you guys
know about that oh yeah I know I know
yeah you wouldn't know about that well
the CIA has been involved in Hollywood
in so many different ways especially
when it comes to planting and seating
ideas there's a reason that they promote
certain movies but they do more than
that I mean the dod gets involved in in
a lot of movies especially when it comes
to a lot of military movies a lot of War
propaganda but specifically the larger
psyops the larger implanting of
subconscious ideas is also done by a lot
of these Central controllers where a lot
of people even knowing it I saw that I
thought of a funny idea real quick
before we show your book I'm just like
this shout out for Sheamus because of
good Freedom Tunes where it's like FBI
agents are watching Luke's content they
get assigned to watch Luke and they're
like you need to watch this guy and
watch out for his radicalization and
radicalism and the guys like yes sir you
got it and then it's like six months
later and the guy's sitting there
wearing a tinfoil hat like it's real
it's real and they're like ah Luke got
another one and they drag him off and
but yeah you got a book that's my goal
how many how many FBI agents have you
have you radicalized
I hope I hope as many as I can I'm doing
my best
yeah so this one is you may have heard
of John C Lilly right he's the dolphin
dude uh he's this was part of MK Ultra
uh he he was doing a lot of experiments
with dolphins he actually had a thing
for dolphins is that the guy who was
whacking the dolphin off oh that's all
right that's him why was he doing that
hey paid for her by your tax dollars
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time